all right let's jump in his first story
from Rolling Stone FBI raids star ABC
News producers home Emmy winning
producer James Gordon Meek had his home
rated by the FBI his colleagues say they
haven't seen him since and this was
apparently back in April look at this at
a minute before 5 a.m on April 27th ABC
news's James Gordon Meek fired off a
tweet with a single word facts the
Network's National Security
investigative producer was responding to
a former CIA agent Mark how do you say
his polymeropolis
take that the Ukrainian military with
assistance from the U.S was thriving
against Russian forces Paulie miropolis
tweet filled with uh acronyms and
indecipherable indecipherable to
layperson like itp's UW and ew was
itself a missive from The Washington
Post Pentagon reporter Dan Le Mans blah
blah blah blah okay really what the
story comes down to
is I think we have this tweet here
let's just go through the the quick
bullet points on this one outside ABC
news's James Gordon Meek's Apartment A
surreal scene was unfolding and his
storied career is about to come crashing
down multiple sources failed to matter
say the emmy-winning producer was the
target of an FBI raid none of his
neighbors with whom Rolling Stone spoke
with have seen him since his neighbors
haven't even seen him an ABC
representative tells Rolling Stone he
resigned very abruptly and hasn't worked
for us for months
it's unclear what story if any would
have put Meek in the FBI's crosshairs
well not necessarily it's been reported
by several outlets he was investigating
Biden's withdrawal from Afghanistan and
then abruptly vanished now here's the
best part of the story
Rolling Stone says Meek has been charged
with no crime but independent observers
believe the raid is among the first and
quite possibly the first to be carried
out on a journalist by the Biden
Administration okay well uh I would just
like to point out James O'Keefe does
exist he was also rated by the FBI but
uh here's the story man this is a
troubling Trend now I don't know what
happened to this guy okay the report was
that he was investigating Afghanistan
very very bad day for Biden and I'll and
I'll remind you when you look at the
aggregate polling that's when Joe Biden
went underwater his approval rating was
was it was higher than his disapproval
Afghanistan happened he flipped the
Democrats right now they're desperately
trying to reverse that narrative and win
back support but the economy is just
it's beating them down then you get a
guy who's working on this big story gone
well Rolling Stones is also reporting
right now that he might have had
classified information and that's why
the FBI raided him but we have to
understand that that what What's
Happening Here is not out of the
playbook out of the democratic party
when Joe Biden was was vice president
the Obama Administration terrified
newsrooms just like they did weddings
and hospitals all throughout the Middle
East with their drone strikes and Obama
used the Espionage Act more than any
other president before him to
specifically put a record number of
journalists and their sources in jail so
we have to understand here this is the
continuation of the Obama doj FBI that
prosecutes people that wanted to do real
journalism they went after James O'Keefe
they probably went after this guy we
don't know all the details here but he
quit his job he he didn't publish his
book and he disappeared people can't
find him of course people are
automatically some people are going to
go off and say oh maybe they Michael
Hastings him uh which is another
journalist that also died under the
Obama Administration also had allegedly
classified direct information during the
Obama admination while investigating
who's he investigating he was
investigating or a top General that was
uh you know that that he was going to
expose and he came out and said hey you
know he tried to use his neighbor's car
he said they had people following him so
so again what the Democrats are possible
what they could possibly do is
unspeakable with what they already did
with the Obama Administration okay what
we know from the Obama Administration is
that more journalists and whistleblowers
were charged with the under the
Espionage Act and other charges then all
of the president's presidents combined
what we know about Michael Hastings is
that who was he was it was it Hayden you
want to Google this was Hayden it was
another uh topic he was investigating
some top General guy and then one day he
shows up to his neighbor's house saying
he needs to borrow their car or
something about he saw someone under his
car tampering with it the next thing we
hear John Brennan Brennan CI director
John Brennan the next thing we hear is
that he was speeding down Wilshire
Boulevard
uncontrollably and slammed into a tree
and his car burst into flames like two
in the morning yeah so the one people
were like maybe he was drunk and he just
depressed and suicidal and just hit the
gas and just didn't let go other people
were like maybe they watched he went to
his neighbors and said my car was
can I use your car please because
someone was messing with my car it's not
the same no you never said no do you
guys remember when uh Sheamus Freedom
tunes that he produced a debunking
left-wing uh memes video and there's
this researcher who made the pyramid
it's the reverse pyramid of conspiracy
theories have you seen this I don't
think I've seen that one there's a so
this this pyramid shows like on the
bottom it's conspiracy theories that are
true and it's like you know MK Ultra it
happened we know the documents are
completely classified and then at the
top it's like anti-semitic point of no
return and the funny thing is it says
something like Epstein is true at the
bottom and then it says powerful uh
individuals trafficking children is
considered a conspiracy theory and it's
like bro that's the same thing like the
Epstein thing that's what it is Guillain
Maxwell's in prison for trafficking
miners it's not a conspiracy theory
anymore she's been convicted now you
know who was it I'd love to see that
list but here's the funny thing like
after something like that happens one of
my favorite stories is Chris I think it
was Chris Reagan tweeting that when
Epstein dies he gets into an Uber and
the Uber driver turns around immediately
and says yo that guy didn't kill himself
and like that's the that was the
cultural shock when that story dropped
so when you hear that a national
security reporter here's the story from
the daily message out ABC national
security producer hasn't been seen since
April when FBI mysteriously rented his
house journalist was writing a book
about Biden's disastrous withdrawal
withdrawal from Afghanistan he abruptly
quits tells the guy he's working the
book without I'm out you know I don't
have anything to do with this and now no
one his neighbors haven't seen him his
colleagues haven't heard from him we
actually someone we work with I'm going
to keep the details you know vague
because we're trying to investigate this
tried reaching out because they know him
and they're like yo he's not responding
so uh I don't know but let me just tell
you the conspiracy theorists scored a
whole bunch of points over the past
couple of years we are well past the
point where we just dismiss these things
as far-fetched a journalist was rated by
the FBI and went missing James O'Keefe
was rated by the FBI his Saving Grace is
that he's famous and people got their
eye on him but I wouldn't be surprised
if something really crazy happened here
I'm just realizing that this was in
April so has has there been research to
note like what's his family say like
where is he like I mean it's the guy
like truly missing from his family
friends everyone I mean his neighbors
haven't seen him like apparently they
reached out to him so that's that that's
why we're here talking about it yeah I'd
like to know what his family has to say
or if he is a family yeah
don't know you would think if he was
married or had kids that they would have
been at least vocal about it and if
they're not vocal about it then they're
in on it or they're scared right yeah
meaning that they're in on it like they
know something well look I mean when the
FBI shows up at your door breaks it down
and points a gun at your family member's
head I mean that's a message right there
and when you do that to journalists when
you do that to people that that
whistleblower when you do that when when
people try to get accurate truthful
information to the general public you're
not on the good side here I mean I think
it's pretty clear and obvious we used to
have journalists we used to have
whistleblowers we used to have things
like you know Watergate we used to have
uh there's another you know comment here
that's an adult comment linked to of
course a whistleblower that goes deep a
part of someone's jugular
those situations those scenarios those
individuals can exist under this
Administration mainly because of just
how brutal they are towards journalism
it's like Tim you mentioned that maybe
he had classified information that I
think Luke mentioned that right is
reporting that that there's a potential
that he had classified information and
was going to probably uh blow the
whistle on on something even more
nefarious to already a very nefarious
nasty story and another thing that kind
of boggles my mind is you know why are
journalists puppeteering why are they
cheerleading this Administration that is
literally punishing them that is
spreading fear in The Newsroom that is
terrifying them from even doing their
job I I don't understand it uh I do on
some levels but the general public
should be asking some serious questions
what's that that phenomenon where slaves
will start to love their slave master
Stockholm yeah Stockholm syndrome it's
like journalists are in a state of such
shock and Terror that they're being the
the the government's spying on their
their like I don't think most
journalists are afraid of this
government I think they're a little too
cozy yeah yeah it's it's well I mean no
no no I
I think technically Ian's right
journalists are in a state of fear the
people you're referring to Seth aren't
journalists they're you know government
shills they're masquerading as
journalists so the people who are actual
journalists this is what happens to them
yeah you get raided by the FBI I mean
look at James O'Keefe the FBI raided his
house the whole thing is is is nonsense
and then the Rolling Stone has the nerve
to be like this could be the first time
it's like bro
first what is that either or possibly
the first time when people point out
James O'Keefe got rated the response
from all of these people on Twitter is
he's not a journalist
no he is a journalist James he is a
journalist and he has news organizations
defending him these people don't like
him personally so they say he's not a
journalist but it's like just because
you don't like the things he writes the
same thing is true of Alex Jones guess
what surprise surprise Alex Jones is a
journalist oh no now they're all Angry
saying don't you dare conflict the work
we do with Alex Jones if you break down
what they are legally doing and their
protections yeah Alex Jones is a
journalist sorry that's just a reality
but I gotta tell you this when you get
these corporate shill quote unquote
journalists that make fake news up and
claim things like Ian Crossland as a
conservative and then have the nerve to
insult Alex Jones oh I a rum if I say I
find it laughable shout out to Jezebel
for writing that bizarre article by the
way
conservative commentator interesting
Society where people appreciate the
government's class of ability to
classify documents if they didn't have
that ability we'd have been overrun and
conquered because we would have lost
Wars like World War II you need secrecy
but at the same time we also glorify
journalists that like expose the the
corruption within the government by you
know it maybe not receiving classified
documents but I don't know how they well
like Julian Assange for instance who he
received like those that was a
classified video the uh what is a
collateral murder where it shows the
soldiers like just from a helicopter
like gunning people down in civilians
gutting civilians down look what they do
to Assange yes and so we've got both
dichotomies like there's Heroes on you
know you could and they're at odds but
they're both on our side I just very
strange I think the U.S government is
full of criminals and corrupt
Psychopaths and then you have people
like Jillian Assange who are like I'm
going to expose evil people right
technically he's a criminal like he got
classified information and revealed no
that was not a criminal at all
yeah it is actually he's protected by
the First Amendment and he's not even
American Center to receive and disperse
classified information you're allowed to
do that the New York Times does it every
day yeah there's whistleblower laws that
protect individuals that come forward
and say hey there was some wrongdoing in
our government many people tried to go
through the official Avenues and and
they of course were told to shut up you
just can't have stolen the documents
himself but if they're provided to him
he has the ability again like he said
that's what journalism they do that all
the time but like even if he knows
they're stolen yes yes I can't commit
the crime but if someone else does it
for me then I'm on the clear it doesn't
adore you if they didn't direct them to
yeah right right you can't you you can't
be if you're a journalist and someone
comes to you and says I have a diary you
can be like okay I'll take it yeah yeah
well they look at Trump's tax records uh
what's her name put uh put them on the
show yes I forgotten together how quick
but yeah she put him on her show and was
heroin for it yeah they were cheering I
mean this is really funny there's um
some some leftist organization filmed
some Republican Congressman or something
under undercover pretending to be a
trump supporter saying we need pardons
for the January 6th defendants and he's
like well we got to win the White House
first and they're all like oh we gotta
we got him and it's just like and how is
what James O'Keefe does not journalism
like you do this the same thing and then
claim Veritas is you get that it's
partisan BS you know what we need I I
would say probably the only real news
organization in the country right now
okay that's not fair but the most
prominent National level is Veritas yeah
and I say it's not fair I wouldn't call
any of the local news outlets news or
organizations I wouldn't call E column
results media local media disbursement
the New York Times please propaganda
narrative garbage the the there's a new
album that came out semaphore and it's
Ben Smith formerly of BuzzFeed in New
York Times along with a bunch of other
people who I I think are just terrible
but they're doing reporting now and
they've done some interviews that are
actually quite good and one of them
is this guy this opinion editor from The
New York Times who got fired for
publishing Tom Cotton's op-ed calling
for the military to uh you know stop the
riots and he's basically like they're
trying to Pander the progressives they
had an opportunity to speak out to call
it out and say we're not here to Pander
to you but they chose we're going to be
Mother Jones on steroids or whatever
that's the New York Times it's not news
it's not investigative Journal there's
like when you talk about journalism you
talk about there's reporting where
people are like hey I got a piece of
paper I'm going to read it to you and
report on what I saw then there's people
that investigate investigative
journalists are like here's a piece of
paper I got to figure out where it came
from who wrote it and they'll do all
this work behind the scenes to figure
stuff out that's project Veritas they're
investigators now New York Times Kylie
Chung from Jezebel who wrote this weird
article about me calling me conservative
misquoting me is not an investigative
journalist thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to Tim cast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there